this monologue isn't about brian go away
or the supreme court hearings that's a
done deal but it gave us one priceless
nugget
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context i'm not a biology
that shouldn't be a tough question to
answer if someone asked me hey greg what
is a woman i just show him this picture
yeah
she still makes me tingle
in all the wrong places but why was it
so hard for a judge to answer this
question because we've let the woke take
the clearest distinctions in life and
destroy it and now people are terrified
of facts it's part of the left's
trifecta create victims create new
reasons to call people bigots and give
college professors something to waste
time on usa today came to jackson's
defense but totally screwed it up by
using nothing but gender studies
scholars
yes there are scholars in gender studies
that's like being a tall munchkin
in the health and wellness section
ironically the headline reads marsha
blackburn asked katanji brown jackson to
define women
science says there's no simple answer
yeah the same folks who came up with the
phrase follow the science then ignore
their own advice when it doesn't benefit
their politics so i guess we can't call
jackson the first black woman supreme
court justice because according to them
she might not be a woman
but in reality what is female has been a
simple question for the 300 000 years
humans have existed it's only in the
last decade that idiots have turned it
into a trick question on a biology test
and why because they prefer ideology
over biology so there's no way to
clearly define what makes someone a
woman well i got an idea to put this
debate to rest ask a hundred men off the
street
they'll define a woman as a human being
who has a nurturing side who could be
emotionally strong as a bull who will
always have your back forever and maybe
the most beautiful creatures on earth
but who can't parallel park
a sexist would say
but this is where usa today screwed up
they interviewed only gender studies
experts on questions of biology
that's like interviewing dana perino on
death metal
and they all said jackson was wrong to
even cite biology
you thought jackson was woke when it
comes to defining a woman compared to
these zombies she's andrew dice clay but
this is from the freaks who brought you
two plus two doesn't have to equal four
so they believe the judge punted by
referring to biology according to gender
studies professor rebecca jordan young
there's not even a singular biological
answer to what is a female sarah
richardson another gender expert says
science cannot settle what are really
social questions
so your sex is social not biological and
i thought bill clinton was phony for
trying to redefine what is is no wonder
dudes can share women's locker rooms use
female restrooms and male perverts can
move into female prisons if sex is just
a social thing you can do or say almost
anything
that way a fact changes from what is to
what people say it is
and biology which is based in absolutes
is as unwelcome as katie pavlich at a
peta rally
gender studies is like astrology with
astrology you look up to the skies and
make up stuff with gender studies you
look down in the locker room and then
deny reality julian williams another
gender expert says white supremacy
denied that black women and women of
color were female well then wouldn't you
then embrace biology which refutes that
you know if you think about it she's
using horrible racism to justify erasing
women that logic moves backwards quicker
than me in the ring with tyrus
smart man yeah i am they then deny
reality regarding leah thomas the trans
swimmer who's creaming biological
females in the pool gender professor
kate mason says lots of people are
assigned male at birth have higher
testosterone levels and could never make
a division one swimming team why do we
attribute thomas's current success to
her assigned sex rather than to her long
record as an elite swimmer
well you dope because she was an okay
male swimmer who's now beating
outstanding female swimmers precisely
because they don't have the innate
muscle mass her assigned maleness gave
her you dope she conflates all males not
being better swimmers than elite women
to deny the fact that a mediocre male
can dominate the female ranks how nuts
is that and pardon me for saying nuts i
mean the kind that squirrels eat this
nonsense makes me testy
i'm sorry
so what defines a woman in the article
they say embracing reproductive justice
fighting the inequality of investment in
girls sports and wage discrimination
again it's not biology it's ideology
which means a female could go her whole
life without being female because she
didn't obey the doctrines of gender
studies graduates that's intellectual
fascism not biology and i say that as a
proud woman of color
he's like death valley dry lifeless and
indeed induces a heat rash
host of one nation on saturday nights at
eight brian kill meeting
a smattering of applause right it wasn't
the best introduction ah shut up
like residents fleeing california she's
constantly packing fox news contributor
townhall.com editor katie pavlos
[Applause]
she's like my refrigerator cold and
empty except for beer fox news
contributor cat tip
and his shoe size is minivan my massive
sidekick and the nwa's world television
champion tyrus
welcome to the show brian thank you for
having me i guess
i think this is the fourth show you've
done today
let's let's get down to it you know you
are into sports uh
have you ever considered i mean you have
the hips to identify as a woman and try
out for the girls olympic soccer team
because you love soccer right i think
you could do it well thanks for
believing in me i made number one and
noticing my hips because it's been a
goal of mine um
so
i think we're being trolled
i believe this whole conversation is so
out of left field i i look at the story
of there you go i hope it goes away
today because i hate being mean to
people unlike okay you yes um
and leah leah thomas i mean she's
getting booed in the pool i hate that
she's already already had a probably a
challenging life
and now she wins total silence
and then she comes and lasts the rest of
the tournament obviously throws in the
street but the crazy thing that makes it
so hard to get around is if you're
putting down men it's okay but we're
trying to say okay it's not about me
it's about women so is it fair to women
and that has people's heads ready to
explode and then finally women are
speaking up and saying it's not fair to
my kid it's not fair to me that she is
beating me because six months ago she
was a man beating me now she's a woman
and i don't think i made any sense no
you did you did i hate i hate getting
booed at the pool
you gotta put in an extra bathroom
you never have chili before you swim
katie
ignored those no uh coming in the pool
with that problem sign yes
please define what a woman is since
brian has never seen one outside fox and
friends right yeah yeah
true
i think if you ask a lot of teenage boys
too they'd be like i don't know what a
woman is either brian it's totally fine
scientifically a woman is a human being
who's an adult who has two x chromosomes
that's the easiest scientific way to put
it i'm really glad the judge wasn't
asked something like complicated about
the constitution like to find emoluments
or something like that when she's
supposed to be interpreting the law in
the u.s constitution and i think people
are who are opposed to her nomination
it's not
necessarily that they're opposed to her
obviously but they do have questions of
if you can't define woman how are you
supposed to look at the law
and interpret more complicated issues
especially when women are deeply
embedded in the law when it comes to the
issue of abortion or title ix one thing
i want to say about leah thomas a year
and a half ago leah thomas was will
thomas swimming on the men's team so
this is not like a lifelong
situation here you know what i'm talking
about um what about women crazy katie
this is i mean what are we talking about
i mean i mean what's with these women
why are so many women on the set i don't
know man and she just destroyed you dude
typical chick man i know let's go out we
gotta go get some beers after this right
and then find out what a woman really is
yeah i don't even know what that means
do i and we'll never get beers no we
would i can't stand you
pull it right off
does not want to do it you know kat um
are you surprised that there were that
many gender studies experts to be
interviewed it seems like all of them
all they do is get interviewed by
reporters well they're probably not busy
they're not like yeah yeah they're not
like icu nurses like i'm sure they were
available for the call whenever yes
that's true but that's all they
interviewed i think that means they
might that usa today might have had an
alturi or motive absolutely and i look i
think the reason why
this stupid of an answer to the question
where it came from because it was it
upset conservatives for the obvious
reasons but then these gender studies
professors were also upset because she
brought biology into it yes and the
reason why was because she was terrified
to answer the question which i've
admitted before i get whenever i'm asked
about gender even though i do have a
gender i just my brain's like danger
danger danger because when you talk
about this issue there's people like
waiting to pounce on you for saying the
wrong thing and you're not allowed in
the public square anymore which is the
worst thing ever for everyone that's not
the same thing as acceptance yeah to
make people terrified to speak about
something the only true terror to the
point where you black out is what could
have happened to give an answer like
that yeah
what you're talking about now is that we
always worry about this external
censorship but now it's internal
censorship
i love the fact that that article was in
the health and wellness section there
was nothing healthy or well about that
and well it couldn't have been the
intellectual section either because
as you read this article you get
stupider
i was drooling on myself and trying to
peel a banana back i couldn't figure it
out after i read it
so not only is
to define what a woman is
undoable it's also apparently racist
yeah so
they
yeah yeah they yeah they found a way to
link this one right in the middle so
back when uh racism was fashionable
and uh you white folks didn't like
sharing bathrooms you were very direct
and clear on who could use what bathroom
and they said white women only not black
women so therefore they were saying that
black women weren't women and i just
wanted to say
no they acknowledged they were women
they just didn't want black women see
racism was about the color of skin they
didn't care if they were packing ovaries
or not mm-hmm
so are you back ovaries or are you
packing ovaries in fact ovaries were
always with you packing this you
wouldn't know right yes you're right
yeah no i i'd like you to keep talking
stop me
packing is like i if i'm packing a gun
it's on me that's what it means you
understand you before the show told me
you were in in the rap game and you were
accepted and then you messed this up
so i'm sure you're gonna have an
interesting text message going you don't
know what packing is
you're back to folk music that's
actually like that that is actually just
like to say
on behalf of of men everywhere to the
people who the external people keep
doing this
shut the [ __ ] up we know what a woman is
move on there you go hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else